okay this is super super super cute so  nine-year-old cent print the president  three dollars and gets a letter back in  return Elijah was very concerned Davies  from Tennessee because he heard from his  parents that President Trump was only  going to take a salary of $1 how is this  gonna be take a listen  how is he gonna eat or drink or you know  pay if he needs to pay for his belt  water bill or anything oh my god so back  in January Elisha sent him the three  bucks he got the letter back he was very  excited including the $3 Aloha to make a  difference in this community and to  think big and dream even bigger so he  reinvested my friend runs a  correspondence office Oh was a good job  Wow good job why didn't a mark I didn't  drop her name well oh you're really  important drop it like it's all people I  know people that do important stuff too